so where did you start doing stand-up
San Diego we started right we can talk
about all kinds of [ __ ] right you start
at the store down there or no no I did
some like shows at the store but it was
the comedy palace and I did a bunch of
open mics and Robert open up the
original madhouse
oh the original the original madhouse in
the back of a Chinese restaurant what
did you ever do shows with that fan yes
he kind of guy man okay good you and
that fan man you guys are like my hero
Jimmy you were gonna say Bobby and death
enter on the same level
man see you guys trying to get me know
when I was 15 watching you guys in high
school yeah you guys are both my comedy
heroes on the same level man and then
you know what and that fan really helped
me out in the beginning of my career
honestly I know he really did he helps a
lot of people he's a great guy did he um
you never paid him for anything though
no okay yeah cuz he does just bring her
shows he does yeah he does you do those
I did those I ran a couple of them too
oh you're a part of his regime I was he
was so intense man yeah he's an intense
guy
he has like OCD or something like yeah
he knows when the Sun I'm he was doing a
show in November and he want to do a
seven o'clock show and a nine o'clock so
I'm like Bobby seven o'clock sun's gonna
be still allowed you know the Sun when
it sun's out you don't want to do Santa
yeah yeah and he's like no don't worry
that's that that's after the daylight
saving time so like the sun's not gonna
be out no more like it's something I'm
like holy [ __ ] this guy thought about
everything yeah he thinks about
everything yeah have you seen his
Instagram posts oh it's like very
detailed hashtags and I'm gonna say
something are you okay Bobby something
right I feel like I'm stepping no you're
not no no no Jimmy Jimmy you're a guest
I want out there's nothing you could
just gonna listen I've no there's
nothing
say there's nothing that you can say
that to penetrate me okay
juices flow the juices flow all right
this is the Lord's comic deep birthday
almost coming up so I want to say this
Jimmy do you yes I have seen his
Instagram and I will also want to say to
you that I'm obsessed with it it's great
fantastic case in point the other day
case in point the other day he because
of the fires in LA yeah he had a mask on
and he's doing promoting and he's
walking down the street he has a mask
he's always promoted right but the sky
was blue
there's no fire there stuff like that is
incredible
yeah yeah it's incredible he he likes to
a lot of hashtags has to like it fits we
did a photo right here that was her you
- tag Brown table he would hashtag
candle right a thousand hashtags
he's one of my [ __ ] idols - man you
don't people even know man I learned
from him man he's the best did you come
up first did he come up first I started
first yeah in saying all right yeah
in terms of Asians in San Diego and what
Wally Wong oh my god that engineer or
something yeah yeah well how long ago
were you down there then so I started
try ten years ago when I was like 21 I'm
like years ago and then I worked at the
comedy palace for a while and that was
when Robert was running it yeah great
this with the Syrian I know Robert yes
yeah yeah and yeah I did the shows there
I did the tip bucket thing there Wow and
and and all of that and then San Diego
when I left I left maybe when I was like
23 yeah to come back up to like as I
grew up here and yeah they and then they
opened up the ACC the American comedy
club and then Robert opened up the new
madhouse like it became like a huge
comedy boom up there yeah staged like a
la - three legit shows every night oh my
god
yeah yeah so I back when I started
only had the Comedy Store right and some
comments some coffee shops but I started
in 95 there was not no man house there
was not any of that [ __ ] man and I had
to start at the store with Wally Wong
was there all these old heads you know
Kris clobber or zoom in yes you like him
Yeah right yeah he's great yeah he's
great I'm just nodding along I'm so lost
I'm like a feeling anxious and why you
feel anxious now I don't know I feel
like I might be good one dad Frank are
you getting it you're being transparent
with our guys has that fan I've been on
the show no he won't really what's the
deal you've been talking [ __ ] about him
like I'm not talking [ __ ] about have you
been I don't know you are you spa every
time I say that fat people laughing I
feel like man you're a [ __ ] spy that
there is a picture of your deaf out
behind you [ __ ] but I feel like
there's there's some other meaning oh
look at the joy that he takes a good
picture man I don't know so you came to
LA LA right you came to LA back to LA I
want to high school Yeah right
and then
[Music]